[موسيقى]
يبدو هذا منزلا ريفيا في البوسنه والهرسك
لكنه في الواقع بيت يقع بمحاذاه مدرج
الطائرات لمطار سري ايفو الدولي ويحوي
نفقا يمتد لمسافه تقارب الكيلومتر تحت سطح
الارض شيد بين مارس اذار ويونيو حزيران من
عام
1993 خلال حصار سرايفو في خضم الحرب
البوسنيه
[موسيقى]
الدار الحصار الذي استمر لما يقارب الاربع
سنوات على سريييفو كان هذا المكان المدخل
الوحيد لتزويد السكان المحاصرون بالطعام
والشراب والوقود للتدفئه في منطقه تصل
درجات الحراره فيها احيانا الى العشرين
مئويه تحت الصفر في فصل الشتاء وهو النفق
السري الوحيد الذي كان من خلاله يحصل
الجيش البوسني على الاسلحه باختصار هو نفق
الامل كما يسميه البوسنيون هيا بنا
[موسيقى]
حفر هذا النفق من قبل الجيش البوسني لربط
مدينه سراييفو التي حوصرت بشكل كامل من
قبل القوات الصربيه مع مناطقها الريفيه
التي كان يسيطر عليها الجيش البوسني من
الجانب الاخر من مطاريفو اصبح المكان
اليوم متحفا تاريخيا يقصده الزائرون
ليتعرفوا عن قرب على تاريخ الحرب في
البوسنه والهرسك في اجواء من التكتم
والسريه وباستخدام ادوات بدائيه لا تتعدى
المعول والمجرفه استمر النفق الشريان
الرقاصره منذ ذلك الوقت وحتى انتهاء
الحصار عام
1996 تناوب المتطوعون الذين انقسموا الى
ثلاثه مجموعات يخرجون الاتربه وكل ما
يواجههم اثناء عمليه الحفر من تحت مدرج
الطائرات الى الخارج كل مجموعه منهم كانت
تعمل لثماني ساعات
مستخدمين عربه يدن بدائيه
كل من ياتي هنا يشهد على جزء حزين من
التاريخ المعاصر والكثير ممن فقدوا حياتهم
في هذه الحرب هذا النفق انقذ حياه
الكثيرين في سراييفو
[موسيقى]
نفقوا الحياه كما يسمى هنا كان مهما
لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه لسرايفو فضلا
عن الاسلحه والذخائر وخطوط الاتصال
والطاقه الكهربائيه في حرب قطعت اوصال
شعبا كان يحلم بابسط ما يتمنى الانسان
الحياه والامان ليث بزهري
البوسنه والهرسك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات